Yesterday Melania Trump unveiled her official campaign
as First Lady.
A lot of people talking about this.
It's an initiative encouraging kids
to make good decisions called Be Best.
Here's a photo from her press conference.
And yeah, some people are already saying
that Be Best is an odd choice of title and theme,
but Mrs. Trump actually went through a lot of other options
before she landed on Be Best.
Here are just a couple that didn't make the cut.
For example, a literacy program called Hello Here Book.
That was one.
(audience laughs)
Yeah.
She had a fitness program called America Fat Stop No.
(audience laughs)
A pet adoption program called Look It Dog.
And finally an abstinence only program
called Insert There Not There.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers)